من المحيط الى الخليج انظار العرب تتجه
صوب المنتخبات الاربعه السعوديه والمغرب
وتونس والدوله المستضيفه قطر
الملايين يامرون في وصول هذه المنتخبات او
احدها الى الادوار المتقدمته في المونديال
مسيره طويله وشاقه قطعتها المنتخبات
العربيه على العشب الاخضر لترفع اعلام
بلادها في مونديال قطر 2022
البدايه من المنتخب السعودي
الاخضر يشارك في نهائيات للمره الثانيه
على التوالي
والسادسه في التاريخ
94 في الولايات المتحده بعد تغلبها على
منتخبي المغرب وبلجيكا ووصوله للدور
الثاني من البطوله وبحسب التصنيف الاخير
للفيفا يحتل الاخضر المرتبه الواحده 51
المنتخب السعودي تحت قياده مدربه
خلال مرحله تصفيه الاسيويه
في المونديال لكن من دون مشاركه حارس مرمى
اللاعب فواز القرن الذي سيغيب مضطرا
لاصابته اثناء معسكر المنتخب في ابو ظبي
المنتخب المغربي الملقب باسود الاطلس
[تصفيق]
يه في بطوله كاس العالم كان افضل اداء
للمنتخب في مونديال
يتخطى الدور الاول ضمن تصفيات البطوله بعد
ان تصدر مجموعته متقدما على ثلاثه منتخبات
اوروبيه اسود الاطلس كانوا في صداره
مجموعتهم في تصفيات الاخيره لمونديال قطر
جمع الفريق 18 نقطه من سته انتصارات واحرز
20 هدفا بينما لم تستقبل شباكه سوى هدف
وحيد
وبحسب تصنيف الفيفا يحتل المنتخب المغربي
المركز الثاني والعشرين
المنتخب التونسي او نسور قرطاج
يشارك ايضا للمره السادسه في المونديال
وتعادل وخساره هكذا كان مشوارا النسوري في
التصفيات وصولا الى الجوله الحاسمه ضد
منتخب مالي النسور فاز خارج ارضهم وتعادل
داخله لتعم الفرحه ارجاء تونس بالوصول الى
المونديال
المنتخب التونسي يحتل المرتبه الثلاثين
اخيرا منتخب قطر او العنابي صاحب الارض
لم يسبق للمنتخب القطري الوصول الى
نهائيات كاس العالم لكنه تاهل مباشره
لمونديال 2022
بصفتهم منتخب الدوله المنظمه ويحتل المركز
الخمسين في تصنيف الفيفا
العنابي شارك في تسع مباريات وديه خلال
عام 2022
وفاز في مبارتين ايضا
شاركونا اراكم من هو المنتخب العربي الذي
سيصل للادوار المتقدمه في مونديال 2022